agora a cor que eu ficava puto e me
tirava do sério Era Quando minha irmã
mexeu nas minhas coisas as vezes ela
Apareceu alguma coisa que era minha e
não era uma coisa que tava assim largada
em cima da mesa não assim que dava para
pegar e usar não era uma coisa que eu
tinha escondido assim ou seja ela fuçou
procurou mexeu nas minhas coisas eu tava
mexendo nas minhas coisas tudo sabe Ah
tu para tu sai tu sai em cima de mim sai
me solta me solta me solta me solta me
solta me solta meu cabelo solta eu tô
falando solta eu tô falando solta
primeiro solta o tempero
tô falando
isso eu tô dizendo tô me solta me solta
me solta tu me solta pegava a mãe é não
eu tava só brincando mas era só
brincando passa passa para dentro que
tudo tá ai ai só que eu era mais nova
não apanhava em quem que Ela batia em
mim ai ai ai era ela que tinha mexido
das minhas coisas e eu capoei e a briga
desse jeito minha mãe chega perto